voici le 49e états des états unis on ne
fait pas plus au nord il a été acheté de
manière peu courante dans l'histoire par
la mairie corus en 1867 pris 7 millions
200 mille dollars
l'arpentent neige n'a pas beaucoup
augmenté depuis le week end
vous pouvez acheter vous aussi un
lotissement d'un pied carré et devenir
pionnier en alaska pour un dollar
en même tarif vous pouvez également vous
transformer en chercheur d'or dans une
mine dans les pépites sont à ce qu'il
est trop
c'est l'été le soleil ne se couche pas
il reste assis sur l'horizon comme un
chien fidèle toute la nuit à quelques
heures que ce soit ils se mirent dans
l'eau qui lui renvoie équitablement sa
lumière
il a donné le signal du dégel les
constructions de glace enchevêtrés
empilées les unes sur les autres au
hasard du froid ces fonds dont en
douceur glisse et disparaissant en
silence d'or tic
et
mesqui mauvais à la chaîne comme
d'autres au supermarché pour se
ravitailler peut-être pour se réchauffer
elle se fait précéder par un attelage de
chiens accrochés les uns aux autres
comme les wagons d'un train est égaré
dans le désert un train où il y aurait
plus de locomotive que de vagues où
il est à l'affût de ce qu'on peut
appeler les grosses pièces le flop
l'ours blanc la baleine
il faillait adroitement à travers les
canaux provisoire d'une sorte de
villeblanche inexorablement voué à la
disparition
essai
cl tu as un phoque qu'il est content
mais il y aura à faire aux grévistes de
la fz6 c'est une baleine il n'y aura pas
de grève on se demande bien pourquoi et
le village tout entier lui adressera de
bruyantes sollicitations mais les danses
sont quelque peu alourdis par le costume
et c'est peut-être pour l'oublier qui a
été mise au point cette joyeuse
cérémonie de la couverture ou l'homme
envoyés dans les airs comme une crêpe et
d'une retombée du bon côté c'est à dire
sur ses pieds c'est la chandeleur des
neiges
au nord les estiment à quelques 1600 km
au sud les indiens les premiers
ignorèrent longtemps la présence des
seconds et vice versa c'est une garantie
de bon voisinage
dans la partie méridionale de la sq
ketchikan est la capitale mondiale du
saumon et le royaume des jouets géants
pour grandes personnes c'est totem
indien raconte l'histoire des tribus
guerrières qui repoussèrent
l'envahisseur russe lors d'une première
tentative
mais les russes devaient finalement
triomphé après de sanglantes batailles
établir leur capitale à sifca et les
c'est paradoxalement un témoignage
pacifique sous la forme d'une église à
l'oriental qui a poussé là comme un
pavot
aujourd'hui les combats sont inscrits
sur le livre du passé le passé à son
passif et si l'on fabrique encore des
totems c'est pour l'amour de l'art
c'est aussi par simple amusement que la
jeunesse s'exercent aux danses rituelles
car personne n'y croit plus nine se
secoue juste tout cela peut bien vouloir
dire
enfin l'alaska ses villes ses jeux ses
plages on pique nique ces terrains de
sport une capitale juno et 56 mille
kilomètres le corps
découpé dans une terre fertile en sorbet
m
là
vous
m
cinquante six mille kilomètres de côtes
plus qu'aucun autre état américain
qui dit qu tu dis mer océan
longtemps mais c'était avant que
l'alaska ne découvre l'amérique
ce pays en noir et blanc a vécu de là
mais ne saisine épuisable profondeur de
la pêche et du poisson richesse
évangélique du pauvre
m